What were the band? It's all, we all get
paid the same. Right? When I took idle,
Katrine started making some paper.
Get that paper.
Fuck yeah. Is that what you're already
made fun of? Me and, but believe me,
did you do it just for the money?
No, but, but no. You know why I did.
Why? Because I thought nobody knew
who I was. Everybody knows this guy
singing. Nobody knew you
over. He knows this guy. Oh,
he was a human. My Mom's passed away
and she said, she said, you know,
they need to see that side of you.
You as a person,
but you just used an American idol
was the best way to show that.
I thought was the first
thing was what else was,
I had no managers back then that had
the good sense to offer me anything.
I got the offer from Marti Fredrickson.
I got, how long ago was this?
How long have you know?
200020101111 to 12 I get to sit next to
j Lo and Randy Jackson at motherfucker.
Beautiful Guy.
Jj Long J Lo's beautiful.
You know what us men need.
I think what everyone needs is a word
called incentive, right? Is it her ass?
It was her acid time. I'd look at
it all the time, but she'd say,
you're harassing me. And I'd say
who's ass her ass? Yeah, I know.
But the funniest fucking thing is we would
do all three of us and I think that's
missing now, but all
three of us, you know,
to do American idol,
you got to go to des Moines,
Iowa and in a gym and you're all set
up with a whole crew and you know,
three people with these microphones,
you know,
the 12 foot mics hanging down over your
head like this and 12 cameras and high
def up Europe was who and in 50 40
people a day would come through all these
1516 year old,
17 year old little trollops with you know,
red lipstick on and push
up Ra's and going to
get outta here. You know,
after the eight, after,
after the 30th 40th one you're sitting
there doing this. Right. You know,
so he just got to,
you got to do,
you need to have incentive from each
other and sometimes it would get,
so it was just shit burned out
after the 40th person, 50th person.
But that's what people liked though.
There's something about American idol.
We'd like really talented people, but
we also like people who are delusional.
Yeah. And we trust me. It took me about
two weeks to get into it because I told
myself I am never going to tell some
young girl that can't sing,
that she can't sit and get the fuck
out of here like that other guy.
You know what? I don't
like him. Yeah. Simon,
I don't like your music besides which
it's country and I don't like country.
I heard him say, yeah, that seems not
that super, but that's also foolish.
He's a weird case, isn't he? Because he's
not a singer. Well, you know what, he's,
whatever he is. I said, I'm
singer. How can I say that
to a girl? It's going to be,
there may be some days breastfeeding
her baby and wants to sing.
Maybe she wants to her baby's second.
She's sitting on her bed on
the bed and wants to sing.
But JLL told her she can't,
I didn't have it in me.
I'd rather like you shouldn't have it
in you. I mean that's his Shtick, right?
His shtick is to be a mean guy.
Yeah. And people liked that.
They liked that mean guy. They would,
they would say to me, you kind of,
come on man, take it up and let's
say that, that the producers,
they don't want the fuck they're doing.
They're the ones who uh,
they got me a couple of times ago.
Did they,
they got you to turn it up and then you
feel bad about it. Disingenuous. Well,
you know what I mean? Like there would be,
it would be moments where we were
parked. We're an, like I said, hey,
where are some Texas?
I look over and
the boom started going like this.
Right.
And I started getting it and they would
say, number one, cause it was in the shot,
you know, you know, and then so I would
whip out my a limerick, you know, those,
I go time for a limerick
and stop everybody.
Everyone was taught by say something like,
you know,
I want some metal horror from Dallas.
She used the dynamite stick for a Phallus.
They found her vagina in North Carolina,
in her asshole in Buckingham
Palace and the fucking,
you'd see the boom going like this.
The place would was just enough to
bring it up and we finished two more.
We leave. But it was fun like
that and it was a good pay day.
So when you're asking me to
have a house Somali, yeah.
And I was made fun of for doing that. Oh,
who made fun of you for doing that? Ah,
Joe Perry didn't think
it was a smart thing.
He said this one step under Ninja turtles
and he's my bro and I read that and I
thought I went, what the fuck
would he, Joe, keep in mind
when I'm alone by myself,
I went, does he write, when
do I thought to myself,
would Bob Dylan do this? Yeah.
I had those thoughts right.
Kind of fucked me up for a minute,
but then I went,
salt doesn't have a house on Maui does.
No, I didn't have one. Then what I wanted,
one, I got a house. He's like, how
much, much money that guy's got?
I'm sure you know, it's probably got a
house. So it took idol and I, you know,
I never,
I.